before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
there's always time for one last
brilliant scene
thank you
[Music]
hey there folks should probably catch
you up on what exactly is going on here
well a couple of years ago a bunch of
YouTubers got together in honor of it
being announced that Christopher
Eccleston would be returning to the role
of the Ninth Doctor through big finish
audio adventures and we put together a
playlist of videos called one fantastic
scene where a bunch of us picked our
favorite scene of the Ninth Doctor and
this time with the end of an era Jody
Whitaker leaving the part it's time
for one brilliant scene there is a
playlist whole bunch of other people are
involved in this there'll be a link to
the playlist down in the description so
this for me selecting one scene was
actually difficult and I know some
snarky people are going to be like I
couldn't find a good one actually the
issue I had was that most of the
episodes I like the best with uh Jody
Whitaker's era
are episodes that don't have a single
scene that sort of works as the
exemplary moment of the whole thing like
I think about the episodes that I enjoy
I love can you hear me I like even the
dialects I actually even now having
rewatched it still like power of the
doctor but there isn't really one single
scene that I'm like that that's where it
all comes together the way that I had
off the top my head with Eccleston
so trying to think of something that Not
only was an episode I liked but was a
single scene that I could point to and
go that
the stuff that I like about Whitaker's
era is pretty much exemplified right
there
it was tricky
but going through and thinking about my
favorite episodes
I did land on one so it's time for me to
talk about it takes you away and more
specifically towards the end with the
solutract otherwise known as
the Frog scene why is there frog in here
now even though I'm gonna be focusing in
on this one scene I do still have a
little bit of setup to do so this is an
episode that starts with the doctor and
the fam finding a young girl in a remote
area whose father has disappeared he
left and told her you can't leave the
house or something out there and it
takes you away she thinks her father has
been taken away by this thing It
ultimately transpires that he has passed
through what's called an anti-zone
linking two different universes to a
place where he thinks his dead wife is
still alive once the doctor and the
companions get there it becomes clear
very quickly that's not what's going on
what they have encountered is something
called the solutract and that is a
sentient universe that has taken the
form of initially this man's wife and
then it also tries to tempt Graham by
taking the form of his late wife Grace
who he met at the start of the season
and it wants them to to stay that's it
just stay and not for some nefarious
reason not for some master plan not to
sap their life's energy just
because it's lonely
because it is its entire universe there
is nothing else in the place where it
exists besides itself
and it wants someone else there
but it's all unstable it's all coming
apart and if this universe goes it runs
the risk of destroying the connection
between this universe and ours and
through that connection destroying our
universe as well
things are destabilizing everything's
coming apart the doctor has gotten the
companions out and needs to also get
this guy who was the original person who
came here thinking it was his late wife
and
she needs to get him away she kind of
pitches herself as a better option you
want a whole universe
someone who has seen it all and that's
me I will be your company I will be your
friend I can offer you more than him
I've experienced more of the Universe I
can share more with you than he can you
can't you can't keep this whole thing
going with both of us here let him go
and I will stay and saw you track
banishes him
and we go into a white void the doctor
walks through it and that asks
a very simple question why is there a
frog in here and there on a chair
is a talking frog
why do I love this so much well
first of all this exemplifies an aspect
of Science Fiction that's actually
pretty core to a lot of my favorite
science fiction I'm pretty upfront about
the fact that I adore Douglas Adams and
what I like especially about things like
The Hitchhiker's Guides of the Galaxy is
that it is ridiculous and very very
funny and absurdist but the absurdism is
inherently baked in and justified by the
simple premise of space it says is big
really big you just won't believe how
vastly hugely mind-bogglingly big it is
anything can be out there including
stuff that makes
no sense
it's like taking the ideas that
Lovecraft only saw Horror in
that somewhere out there there are
things beyond our comprehension the
universe is so great and Grand that we
are insignificant there is madness out
there where's Douglas Adams and people
with that kind of mentality go yes there
is madness out there
it's kind of funny
now the thing is this is actually a
pretty sincere scene but you have to
address the humor up front because it's
a frog this universe
takes the form of a frog why
my own form is endless
but this frog is a form that Delights me
it's delighted Grace
because it liked being grace and grace
like frogs so it just wants to be a frog
so it's a frog
why do you need more explanation than
that
in a universe and actually in the case
of a story like this a Multiverse this
great and Grand and multi-layered and
bizarre Why Can't This just be the way
it is there's me thinking the day had no
more surprises left I like that there is
no further exploration of why is it a
frog why not a frog
and when you are talking about someone
who travels across the infinite universe
the answer why not
needs to be valid at least sometimes
it's easy to lean on as a crutch to just
get away with crazy coincidences that
saves the story but you know what
sometimes you just have something
bizarre happen
and as long as it's not a massive plot
convenience which this is not
I feel like it adds I feel like it adds
to that sense
that the universe will surprise you
and that's something the doctor herself
expresses you are
modest most
beautiful thing
I've ever experienced unfortunately this
is where the inevitable happens the
doctor points out that things are still
destabilizing
she can't stay
the salty track needs to let her go
otherwise they're both going to die and
the thing that I really like here is
while there was a Melancholy and a
sadness
the thing I'm going to miss the most is
the people there is wonderful sincerity
when she expresses friendship and
amazement towards this frog I wish I
could stay and here's the thing
I know that say for instance Matt
Smith's doctor I had the Mantra the
doctor lies
not every doctor does
Whitaker's doctor in particular actually
seems really bad at it
and I actually think that's part of the
reason that she has a tendency to clam
up and shut herself off and is not
nearly as open
to the companions to the fam
because she's not good at lying she's
not good at Faking It
so when she speaks when she chooses to
say something there is always a
sincerity to it and she pours some of
the most sincere delivery into these
lines expressing
sadness
sorrow amazement towards this frog and
that sadness around the idea that she
does have to leave
you're gonna have to let me go and keep
on being brilliant by yourself
there is still very clearly from her
delivery so this really is a really
great moment of acting from her on top
of the wonderful crazy bizarreness going
on
you really get how sincerely
she wishes she could do more
would she miss our universe yes of
course
but I do think she would have stayed
if that Universe had destabilized
she said she would
I think she would have maybe with a hope
eventually that she could talk this
thing into letting her go again but
that sincerity
in the face of something this bizarre
because she has the same instinct to be
kind to this sentient Universe I was
kidnapping people and is now taking the
shape of a frog because it's lonely
as she does to her human Companions and
every person that she ever tries to save
this combines a wonderful sense of
weirdness that I love with one of the
best acting moments that Whitaker was
given and she just gives such sincerity
and Care in those lines
and between those things in an episode
that I already enjoyed for the tension
in the atmosphere and again the
weirdness
in an already good episode
this is absolutely
one brilliant
scene
and that is why
I wanted to talk about it share my
thoughts with you
what is it for you what is a single
scene specifically not just in the Arab
but specifically featuring Jody
Whitaker's doctor
that you think is a true standout I'll
tell you the other one I considered it
was from flux I think it was the fifth
one survivors of the flux where she has
a confrontation moment with a grand
serpent
that that one was in the running that's
a really good scene but I want to hear
more
even if you didn't especially like what
occurs era because spoilers I didn't
especially like Whitaker's hour but I
can still find stuff that's like that
though
that was good
this video is here for positivity for
celebration
the air is over
what were the good moments what was the
scene you loved
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
check out the other videos in the
playlist there's going to be some great
stuff in there this was so much fun to
do I had a lot of fun when we did it
with the Ninth Doctor and uh maybe it'll
happen again down the line we'll see
patreon is how you can support me in
particular and uh any amount that you
can give is of great assistance but
don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
so that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are brilliant
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
awesome
cool
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin lafolla Tarak the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi Leota Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam
ardiel Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan
Larose and TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]